social media is undoubtedly addictive I
had just turned 22 when I decided to
delete my Facebook account and go
without any accounts such as Instagram
or Twitter for good I struggled with
social anxiety to the degree that I
experienced physical symptoms like
sweating and feeling of my heart racing
if I even just had to call someone over
the phone I would much rather have gone
hungry than take up my Dad's offer to
have free pizza if I ordered it on the
phone nope it was not gonna happen and I
also struggled with body image issues
and self-loathing my childhood and
Adolescent years led me to believe that
I was worthy of love if I did x y z and
so I was very prideful because I believe
that if I admitted to a flaw or a
mistake that it meant that I was a
failure and if I was a failure then I
was Unworthy of love I also allowed
myself to be hurt by others in ways that
I would never want anyone hurt but
looking back I believed that I deserved
it social media it gave me emptiness as
I felt my own lonely heart grow hungry
for love I scrolled through hundreds of
smiling faces with perfect families
perfect vacations perfect fakeness
social media reaffirmed my feelings of
lack the lowest period of my life is one
that I never truly have shared with
anyone other than my husband who at the
time had become my best friend and even
though I know that the people around me
could very well see my depression I had
dropped down to 97 pounds at five foot
seven because I had no desire to eat my
world had lost its color I knew that
people could tell that something was off
but still I felt the need to put on a
smile for the perfect profile photo when
I decided to cut these chains that kept
me from changing the first step for me
was redefining myself this was phase one
in what I call my metamorphosis they're
unfortunately in VHS form so I don't
have them to show you but I have videos
of myself as a one and a half year old
child with my uncle's playfully telling
me that I was ugly and you know a
shameful tone as though I should be
ashamed telling me to pull my dress down
and sit correctly I was a very
well-behaved child actually I obeyed and
As I Grew Older I believed those sorts
of things that I heard I believed that I
was ugly I believe that I was shameful I
believed that I was not enough looking
back at these videos when I was just a
toddler I realized that my entire life I
had lived to please other people whether
in romantic relationships my teachers or
my miserable attempts to try to obtain
my father's Pride my desire for
Perfection or my frustration when I got
an A minus it was never for me but this
time this decision was different it was
for myself and I actually did face
criticism for it because at that time
all these sorts of social media
applications were relatively new so
everyone had have it for my classmates I
was the weirdo but oddly despite the
criticisms it felt right because this
time I was not trying to please anyone
else other than myself and in this
process I had to learn more about myself
what hobbies did I even have besides
social media what did I want for my
future and what kind of a person do I
want to be I now had time to do things
for myself and this phase was both
exciting but also scary at the same time
but after this phase I faced a different
obstacle this next phase that I
experienced was easily the most
difficult and I would say that it lasted
for several weeks for me and it was
facing the dopamine Spike addiction
facing that dopamine Spike addiction
without reverting into other negative
habits was very difficult I realized
that I had become so addicted to
checking for notifications that even
though I didn't have social media
anymore that now I was reaching for my
phone just to check a case somebody had
sent me a message maybe someone sent me
an email maybe I missed a phone call it
was just kind of an instinct to check
for my phone and not only that but it
caught myself also wanting to share any
and all information that was the least
bit interesting so because I didn't have
a way to share it on social media now I
just I had that desire to share it with
somebody in a way this was kind of a
humbling experience for myself because I
had not realized how addicted I had
become to checking for those
notifications I would just instantly
grab from my phone the moment I felt
bored and of course there was nothing to
check and unfortunately or very
fortunately whatever way you want to
look at it I quickly realized that even
though I had hundreds of friends on
social media I had less than a handful
of friends that I could actually count
on that would actually send me a message
or I could expect a phone call from but
strangely this actually brought a sense
of Peace because at least now I knew who
my real friends were and this led me to
the next stage finding peace in solitude
by now I had had some practice in
changing negative habits I had quit my
Coca-Cola addiction which was very
severe I would say I had also gotten rid
of my television when I was a teenager
and I knew that if I was going to change
for the better that I was going to have
to change this negative habit and swap
it out with positive ones so with this
extra time I began to participate in
plays I took guitar lessons and I became
a Lecter at my church
I did as many activities as I could to
force myself to overcome my social
anxiety and this was truly a
transformational period for me if you
would like to know more about how I
overcame social anxiety I will link that
video down in the description box below
and by the way if you are enjoying this
video so far and are getting any value
from it please don't forget to give it a
thumbs up I say that this time was
transformational for me but by this time
months had passed and I realized that I
now could walk very tranquily through a
park by myself but not feel lonely no
need to check a phone no need to take a
selfie no need to share it with anyone I
could be perfectly content with just
soaking in that experience for myself
like just watching how slow the clouds
appear to move on the sky or hearing the
leaves rustling through the trees
this is when I started to live my life
and it allowed me to be more present and
appreciate simple moments and while this
stage was full of Hope and Novelty this
next stage was truly the most freeing
and fulfilling because quitting social
media allowed me to shift my perspective
on not only how have viewed
relationships but how I viewed Humanity
as a whole from egocentrism to love and
to compassion I had not realized that in
caring for superficial relationships and
putting on a mask of perfection I had
become superficial and selfish this was
a hard pill to swallow I had to begin
acknowledging my flaws admitting
mistakes accepting my failures but
contrary to what I had feared in the
past it actually brought me a sense of
self-compassion and this fueled me to do
the same for others I forgave I forgave
and I allowed myself to love and love
immensely and I decided that I wanted to
be the person that would give compassion
and encouragement to others I wanted to
be with the people that were grieving
and be the hand that they would hold and
this is what led me into ICU nursing and
currently hospice nursing where I help
patients who are at the end stages of
life not only manage their symptoms but
also take priority of their emotional
and spiritual struggles as well clearly
I still do have social media as many
viewers like to point out I have this
YouTube channel but I have a different
vision for this channel perhaps we can
have our own Little slice of light and
hope here because most of what we see on
social media only touches the surface I
left ICU nursing for hospice nursing
because I was tired of scratching the
surface of treating bodies and treating
numbers I wanted to dig beneath that
talk about the things that truly hurt
and treat human beings treat Souls so
that that way the healing could happen
from within I hope that by sharing my
experience with you it will be
encouraging and motivating in some way
but I also want you to know that your
experience will be as unique as you are
and feel free to share your experience
in the comments because I know it's also
helpful for other people as well if you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up and subscribe so you won't miss when
I post a new video I thank you so much
for watching and I can't wait to hear
from you in the next one bye for now